dernier volet de notre page d'été
consacrée à l'art de vivre à la
française
nous sommes dans le nec plus ultra le
temple du raffinement
c'est le reportage que nous vous
proposons philippe roy romain pasquier
c'est un décor digne d'un long métrage
sur les métiers à tisser
tout ou presque est restée en l'état le
bruit assourdissant et le rythme cadencé
de dizaines de machines d'un autre temps
le passé et le présent se conjuguent
et je débite de la matière qui est sûre
pommeau de la douche de la rive sur bol
il nous a fait un tabac à lolita
on est allé
les chaînes
puis après on derrière les
vous mettez à toutes les formes
l'appétit la production du ver à soie
vient de chine et dates de 2500 ans
avant jésus-christ ce n'est qu'au 6e
siècle que l'europe suis la filature
industrielle va s'imposer avec ses
kilomètres de cartons perforés
c'est l'intermédiaire entre notre motifs
et la machine
c'est ce qui permet à la machine de lire
et de comprendre en fait le mot comment
le tissu va être construit et par quels
mécanismes les fils vont se lever
par exemple si on prend ce tissu si on
voit que le motif est construit par un
jeu d'armure donc par de satan mais
également une armure intermédiaires qui
va créer un effet d'ombré à certains
moments et
et cet effet là et construire justement
par le carton le processus de
fabrication des tissus en soie
c'est l'histoire d'une longue patience
et d'un réel savoir faire
donc cette issue là c'est le drame à la
vigne il est sans composés 100% en soi
donc là le violette c'est une armure
satiné sur l'endroit est en fait quand
on le retourne c'est l'envers du satin
on voit donc d'un côté c'est violer de
l'autre c'est c'est donc la couleur de
la trame qu'on peut voir c'est un long
processus la sueur pour 15000 fils comme
ça sur cette machine là on va passer
deux jours à peu près après il ya donc
le new age qui dure à peu près deux
jours aussi et après le tissage ça
dépend de nos métiers mais on this 10 à
39 20 jours après ce reportage
nous avons le plaisir d'être reçu par le
pdg de cette société
vous aviez semble-t-il des surprises
pour man bonjour à tous merci pour votre
visite et on a fait quelques surprises à
vous proposer
qui tient à l'histoire de cette
entreprise rose qui fait en 2020 c'est
360 en est aujourd'hui c'est de d'amener
cette entreprise à être un peu plus
contemporaine et c'est ce qui nous a
amenés à créer une
une collection qui s'appelle jardin des
simples et jardins et sam c'est là que
le fait de concilier la soie le tissage
de la soie avec des matières végétales
et en fait cette gamme de produits
permet cette démarche avec un engagement
toujours dans la soie qui nous amène à
replanter des mûriers en val de loire et
de pouvoir associer cette matière à du
lin et du chanvre du bambou et d'autres
matières d'origine végétale ce fauteuil
c'est la deuxième surprise à vocation
très presque dans l'histoire l'idée de
créer un tissu lafayette
donc on s'est inspiré des
des motifs de sa chambre d'enfant ce de
lafayette
on offrira cette paire de fauteuils avec
ce motif à l'ambassadrice des états-unis
en france on est 80 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires et à l'international et les
états unis est un des marchés dans
lequel on veut vraiment s'implanter de
façon beaucoup plus forte cette
entreprise il y encore peu est en
liquidation judiciaire
pourquoi vous jeune chef d'entreprise
avait décidé d'y croire et de la
racheter pour en faire quoi
je trouvais insensé voir un tel savoir
faire disparaître de delaplace
tourangelle toujours été la première
capitale de la soie puisque c'est une
décision de louis 11 en 470 qui ne
trouvant pas la possibilité de créer une
manufacture à lyon a décidé de la faire
à tour donc il a par lettre au château
d'amboise fait en sorte d'accueillir des
soyeux italiens notamment à tours pour
créer la première manufacture entre eux
ce qui plantait les mûriers entre les
séries sculpteur qui élève les vers à
soie la filature et le tissage on
arrivait à avoir une une filière total
est en fait aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer
de relancer cette démarche là en ayant
une une soit une soie médine toi après
une sévère cure d'amaigrissement
les soirées rauzan retrouver le chemin
de la croissance